When we first defined our tables,
we defined the relationship between them
in terms of constraints.
Now we are going to implement
that relationship
into our query using a join.
This join will allow us
to query the weather table
for values from
a specific location setting.
We'll start by adding
a SQL ITE query builder class variable
at the top of WeatherProvider.
We'll initialize the SQL ITE query builder
in the static constructor for the class,
describing the join between both tables.
Note, since both tables
have a column named _ID,
we must explicitly use the TABLE_NAME
in order to disambiguate which _ID
we are talking about in the join.
Then we can define the query.
The query is to find using
the question mark replacement syntax.
These question marks will be replaced
by the query parameters.
Since we allow people to specify
the start date in the URI,
we're also going to add
a second selection
which includes checking to see
whether DATETEXT
is greater than or equal to our parameter.
Next, we'll add a method
to get the weather by location entry,
using the same query builder.
Note, that we fetch
the parameters from our URI.
And build a string array,
so they can be substituted into our query.
Note that if a URI
does not contain a start date,
we actually use a different selection.
Finally, we add the function
into the query routine
of our content provider.